[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir à tous et on ne
change pas une équipe qui gagne on va
parler de l'ukraine terrain d'un phoque
ce prolifique les russes et les
ukrainiens assurent contrôler plusieurs
villes image à la pluie on va
s'intéresser ce soir à la situation de
mario paul henry qui contrôle cette
ville stratégique du sud est à la fois
proche du dombass à la fois proche de la
crimée et sur la mer d'azov on va la
découvrir sur cette carte une ville
assiégée par les troupes russes et
symbole de la résistance une craignait
n'est bien c'est impossible à dire
d'autant qu'il n'y a plus de
journalistes sur place et que ce qui
filtre ce sont des images qui nous
proviennent soit du coup ils craignent
un soin du camp russe et dans les deux
cas est la propagande et là on l'a
suffisamment répété ces dernières
semaines pour que dire que cette guerre
c'était aussi une guerre de l'image
alors justement certaines de ces images
ont été analysés par thomas et d'où des
observateurs de france 24 est vérifié
plus précisément d'abord celle qui nous
viennent de ce conte télégramme le
compte officiel du président tchétchène
ramzan kadyrov on le sait soutien de
moscou on va découvrir ensemble une
vidéo quelques images qui date du 21
mars que voit-on sûr c'est sur cette
vidéo on je sais pas si on peut voir les
images à l'antenne ce sont des voilà des
combattants tchétchènes qui progresse
sur un boulevard ils sont aidés on l'a
vu par des tanks russes et puis on va
voir sur cette encre us la fameuse
marque d'identification le fameux rased
qui ne veut pas dire zorro évidemment
ses soldats il se trouve plus
précisément sur le boulevard morse qui
regardaient c'est ici on est dans l'est
de la ville donc sur le boulevard morse
qui on va revenir sur la publication que
dit elle les combattants tchétchènes
avance avec succès en direction de
marioupol nos combattants nos seulement
élimine avec succès les positions de tir
mais fournissent également une
couverture fiable à leurs camarades à
des formations militaires de russie est
ce qu'il a été possible de vérifier
cette revendication alors
malheureusement non on l'a entendu les
propos sont volontairement vindicatif
mais il n'y a pas de preuve en revanche
on peut essayer on peut analyser les
éléments visuels des vidéos et cd par
exemple de là localisation on peut
retrouver par exemple un élément commun
entre la vidéo du comte de kadirov ce
monument la et celle de google street
view il ya aussi une deuxième vidéo qui
a été publié sur télégramme que j'aurais
bien voulu vous montrer mais ce n'est
malheureusement pas possible elle a été
publiée le 23 mars elle présente des
bâtiments en ruines et des combattants
tchétchènes tout sourire face caméra là
aussi il suffit d'étudier pour permettre
de géolocaliser
l'endroit de l'axé quand on est toujours
sur ce boulevard morse qui donc à l'est
de marib dans l'est de marioupol plus
précisément mais à 350 m un peu plus
haut en direction du centre qui se
trouve à gauche et tout à l'heure on
était pour vous donner une idée à peu
près à cet endroit là là encore il a
suffi de devoir des éléments et des
positions en commun on retrouve par
exemple ce grand immeuble que l'on
retrouve ici avec selon pas d'air en
face c'est évidemment pas la même vue et
puis il ya ce petit bâtiment aux
affiches ou en tout cas aux petites
pancartes jaunes que l'on retrouve ici
sans les pancartes dans les images plus
bas donc celle de google street view
enfin il ya une troisième vidéo
géolocalisés cette fois par le center
for une formation brésilienne ce que
l'on voit ici et on voit ces combattants
tchétchènes on a vu le drapeau devant ce
fameux petit bâtiment et cette vidéo
était a été tournée le 26 mars alors ces
éléments il nous montre quoi ils nous
permettent certes de confirmer la
localisation de ces combattants
tchétchènes à un moment précis en
l'occurrence le 26 le 23 mars etc à
marioupol mais en aucun cas ils nous
permettent d'affirmer que les
tchétchènes contrôler ce port voilà pour
le camp russe qu en est il du camp
ukrainien alors deux côté ukrainien les
images de mario paul elles émanent
essentiellement du bataillon
nationaliste azoff il ya par exemple
cette vidéo qui a été publié sur
toujours sur télégramme on né le 25 mars
une vidéo par drones qui monte ici une
attaque de véhicules que dit la
publication on va revenir un peu plus
sur le texte que des soldats d'azov ont
détruit deux véhicules blindés
d'infanterie russe bmd 2 e.on tuer
l'ennemi sans détruire d'infrastructures
comme tout à l'heure le ton est
volontairement vindicatif de cette
séquence les observateurs ont pu
géolocaliser la scène en repérant des
éléments communs que l'on voit ici en
rouge et en bleu alors en route toujours
vous avez les images du conte télégramme
en bas celle de google street view mais
on est sept fois dans l'ouest de mario
paul donc plus à l'est mais là non plus
il n'a pas été possible de vérifier la
véracité des informations et surtout de
ses revendications faute de contacts
locaux une autre vidéo par drones
également publié sur télégramme aussi
par azoff le 23 mars elle montre elle
des dégâts à marioupol alors le quartier
il a été filmé par nos équipes il s'agit
du boulevard mort ce qui allait s' celui
où officiaient tout à l'heure à les
combattants tchétchènes en clair donc
l'analyse des différentes vidéos
montrent que les deux camps sont là mais
en aucun cas ne permettent d'affirmer
qu'un des deux contrôler entièrement la
ville merci beaucoup pour cette mise au
point anthony merci à vous d'avoir suivi
cette demi heure d'information se
retrouve tout de suite pour un nouveau
journal
[Musique]